[Music]
in there probably hundreds of battle
rail games we've got now of varying
quality the new kid on the block
obviously blackout and we're gonna put
that up against the like a big kid I
guess of four nine that's like still the
incredible huge success that it is but
now the blackouts out and we've had a
few days to play it and like you and
I've been playing a bit in the office I
think it's worth you about how it
compares who it might be for if there's
some stark fortnight fans should they
actually make a leap and try a different
barrel experience so have you found it
so far have you found black oh I've
really enjoyed actually I played a bunch
of different bass Oriole games and
straightaway I felt like I was I hit the
ground running thanks to it being the
Call of Duty game
if you've played a Call of Duty game
which most people have yeah you can
probably get on with this a bit easier
then for tonight where you have to learn
to build and you know shootings not
quite the same as in other games so
there's a lot more to learn whereas in
Call of Duty while it is a bit
complicated at the start would like the
item menu attachments and yeah all that
there's still a lot going on there's
there is some depth there but I
definitely felt like it was easier to
get into and start you know getting in
the top tiers of the ranking and not
just die all the time it's that classic
ecology thing right it's it's happy in
its placement as the like arcade shooter
now right it's kind of separated itself
in the battlefield
this is Cod argument without four went
down the street group college is happy
to sit in the like the arcade sphere and
it's brought that that that flavor that
feel to battery out I feel like it
exists but there's a spectrum of battery
all games let's say let's say the Far
strategic wine is like pub G yeah and
then all the way on the arcade side is
blackout and then somewhere in the
middle fortnight exists it's got that
four nights got a mixture of strategy
and like the movements very arcade the
shootings quite Arkady and then a
strategy comes in with like what you're
building like this is the speed in which
we're building or items to use now the
first thing I noticed really is I hadn't
really realized that I hadn't played a
batterer game in first person in a long
time being in first person feels a lot
more intense with that much closer to
the action and you lose things like
being able to see over a wall
because your first person only I felt
like I could get much more into the sort
of head space of I am in a battle royale
I felt very much like it was me there
rather than my stupid for tonight
character with a llama
around his waist and so it definitely
felt like I was I was thinking more
strategically because of that I was I
was putting myself in the situation and
thinking I have to survive yeah and I
took it way more seriously than with
like for tonight where you do drop in a
map to survive but there's also a lot of
silly stuff to do
whereas in blackout it's like I have to
survive I have to try and stay till the
end and I found I was like camping more
or hiding more and I wasn't just like
running in and shooting people I was
thinking of more about my life then I
wouldn't have a battle really so that's
something I've struggled with the
ecology I find because because it's a
card game right I automatically get into
that Call of Duty mag mindset that I
used to have when I used to play all the
time whereas jumping run and gun play
aggressive super aggressive fight fight
fight fight fight and you can't do that
here you'll you'll get yourself killed
you do have to like I did have to slow
down my my thought process and be like
okay maybe I shouldn't run into this
building like it's it's not multiplayer
to win a battle rial not everyone's
gonna be able to so it's important that
you that the game rewards you for
playing in other ways it needs to be fun
even if you're not getting the top squad
or the top players which I think
blackout is doing pretty well
so another big part of battle Royales is
obviously the map because typically
battle royale games usually only have
one there's one in fortnight there's one
in blackout pub G has like two or three
three-inch they've added gradually but
how did you find the map initially
dropping in the maps in barrel games are
hugely important what I've enjoyed about
blackouts map is like I said it's like
them the marriage of a lot of like Call
of Duty parts right there's there's
familiar areas like like the new town is
like not sealed new town maps like
asylums not the old zombies map there's
bits for that feel familiar even if like
the layouts changed like the flavor of
it is is recognizable I think yeah it's
definitely not it does have diversity
and it is cool when you stumble upon
like a zombies area and you hear that
that's of the noise from the other one
wait new wave knows yeah yeah but that
doesn't make it a bit more interesting
but yeah it'll be interesting to see how
the map evolves because obviously in
fortnight it's constantly changing like
complete sections of the map have
totally changed events happen in the map
we've not really seen that in blackout I
mean granted it's only be out under a
week so there's not much by things like
I think blackout needs to bear that in
mind though yes like you say before
night ill that there'll be big changes
with like a new season or there'll be
gradual change like when the media hit
tilt the tower is week on week the the
towers will start to rebuild and that
would add like a little a little twist
to when you're when you're fighting
there with fortnight I have like my
favorite drops but depending on what
season it is what's happening on the map
like if they've added a new vehicle yeah
you get a different experience
if blackouts weren't smart they'll bear
that in mind but one thing they have
added which is it's important to add
areas for new players so if you're not
familiar with the game you can go
somewhere a little bit quieter so I
think if you're starting out like pick
somewhere quiet to familiarize yourself
with the inventory and then my favorite
thing to do - actually I kind of
practice and get good at the game is
drop like busy areas like constantly
like firing SWAT that's all folks
yeah like the way I got I talk I say
good but okay a fortnight is I was
dropping tilted towers like every drop
for a whole day until I could
competently shoot of mayhem yeah but
like it's jumping right into the deep
end yeah it's it's sink or swim and I
think to get good a batter our gaming
you can't just like [ __ ] for a round
you need to to learn it and get stuck
it is is nice state that you like you
mentioned there are familiar areas like
asylum like estates which I didn't
realize her in the game till I was
walking around was like I recognized
this place so that's quite cool it's
almost like a greatest hits tour of the
Call of Duty franchise and I wonder if
you know potentially if they do back out
again are we gonna get more of that so I
think that's quite an interesting idea
I've not seen done in a game like this
before so I excited to see what they do
and if they keep it fresh because that's
that's the most important thing for me
one thing is super important for battle
games is is its longevity there needs to
be something to keep players playing so
I think the rewards and how the game
that respects your time is super
important
I am I love it when a game is like his
shiny new things that you can buy with
real money or earn in in-game currency
so I'm a sucker for that sort of thing
and that's not everyone's cup of tea but
for me that does genuinely keep me
coming back to a game I have to say it
is my biggest disappointment so far with
blackout because I've played probably 60
or 70 games I've been gradually earning
merit which you get from staying alive
for a long time killing people and
granted that is based a lot down to play
a skill but I don't feel like it's
rewarding me at all like you the more
merit you get the more extra on levels
you go up and there are skins that
unlock at like level 20 and 40 but other
than that I've not felt like I'm getting
anything in return for my time other
than a fun game to play yeah and and
there are some secret like other skins
you can unlock by doing certain
challenges which looking looking at them
but they're very difficult there's some
people that need a reward to get
enjoyment out of it and that's
completely fine I'm the same like I'm
really competitive and I enjoy most
power rail games when I win but not like
we said before in a hundred player game
99 people are going to lose mmm but they
still need to find enjoyment there are
going to be people out there that want
and throws a little like there's small
victories let's say and fortnight
obviously does that really well
it's free-to-play you will get some
stuff playing free but if you invest in
a battle pass then you get like all
sorts of wonderful stuff mmm with the
challenges as well that adds adds an
extra layer of play and that rewards you
with battle pass bonuses and you unlock
more stuff mmm but they black out it's
yeah it's it's a struggle to find that
enjoyment like you find those small
victories
that's that lack of time like hey hey
thanks for playing here's something cool
especially when it's a full priced game
that you've bought call unity I think
like that would be nice to see because
at the minute as well the customization
options are real it's the same and I
thought it was the personalization was
gonna be hey get a cool helmet and look
like a cool dad that's what I want to
see definitely I want them to get silly
with it I want them to not take it too
seriously and we're already a couple of
things like the monkey with the symbol
yes and like there are zombies in it so
it's not like completely serious okay
it's the multiplayer where like there's
all those like super weird like
tongue-in-cheek weapon skins like yeah
previous cool the GBA just have bacon
weapon skins and stuff in like a
acontece of contrast the multiplayer
where nearly every game you're unlocking
something new yeah and that's like that
is a real reason for me to keep playing
but in blackout after 60 70 games I've
unlocked I think an emote and that's
about it and it's like oh I mean it's
still fun to play I am going back but I
don't see me playing at long-term unless
they keep it fresh and make me make me
want to show off what I have done in the
game other than my epsilon level which
at the moment doesn't really mean a lot
for me
so now I've tried a little bit about it
who would you if I've never played about
a rail game before which one would you
recommend and if there was people that
dedicated for tonight who are interested
in trying something new why would you
recommend them black up I think for
newcomers black out might be a bit more
accessible just because of the Call of
Duty heritage I think for fortnight
players who are looking for the next
step for like something a bit more
strategic and challenging in terms of
like shooting and that kind of more
realistic experience black out is a good
option if you think you're going to get
value out of multiplayer and zombies as
well because there is a $60 game so and
four nights free so it's a difficult one
to weigh up really because there are
benefits on both sides but which one
would you pick then it's it's a weird
one getting into fortnight now is
definitely a challenge because there's a
lot of people out there who may at super
high level and sometimes you'll pop
around at someone and then all of a
sudden etosha Harville around you if
people are playing for now and they're
at least tempted to buy call of duty
this is a really good palate cleanser
yeah because it's it's nice and quick
it's rkd one thought I had is that
actually it depends on the system you're
playing I think PC fortnight is a better
experience whereas I think blackout is a
more accomplished and better experience
on console and there's gonna be people
playing on both but yeah that's that's
that's my take on it really but it's
partly gonna be a lot of people out
there that disagree I feel like there's
battery hours pretty hot topic and
people are very loyal to the games that
they've spent a thousand hours in but
you know we look forward to hearing your
thoughts so you can leave them in the
comment section below or you can find me
on twitter at a regular Dave and Bill
I'm the quitters dead and for every
other argument discussion make sure you
come back next week for more versus
blackout has helicopters
[Music]